Carlo is with us in Baton Rouge hi
DeCarlo how are you hey I'm doing well
how about yourself better than I deserve
what's up well I I just wanted to talk
to you me and my wife we have five kids
and we just relocated to Baton Rouge
from Birmingham Alabama and we've got a
triplet boys and they're they're two
years old and you got your hands full
yes sir so we're really trying to leave
a legacy for them amen and we just want
to get your advice we we listen to your
show I think this is actually the third
show that we've listened to but we just
want to get some advice on how do we get
it make that first step not sure so
what's your household income well we're
working off one income and it's 52,000
and we have a debt of right around
100,000 and what's that on this that's
mostly student loans and a little bit of
medical bills with the triplets okay and
what do you do for a living sir I'm a
scientist a scientist okay you have the
ability to add extra income temporarily
well I do work a lot of overtime okay so
that would add to the money you're
talking about yes sir okay well the
first thing we're going to put you on a
tight budget you're already on a tight
budget as much on a written budget where
every dollar behaves and the easiest way
to do that is go to every dollar calm
and use the free app okay iphone or
android either one and it'll do you can
run it off your phone you can run off
your computer either one I don't care
and it's free and get in there and learn
to do a budget you and your wife
together telling every dollar what to do
before it comes in and then and then
when it comes in every dollar has to
behave this is the whip in the chair
with the lion tamer right right make it
behave okay and so you build that out
and then when you can find any money
anywhere in your life by cutting
expenses or increasing income and just
turning that rag over and twisting it
and getting every drop out of that
budget right or the first thing I want
to save a thousand dollars is a beginner
starter emergency fund that's baby step
one then baby step two is going to be a
long slog for you guys that's it paying
off all your debt except your home a
hundred thousand bucks making 50 grand
all right so if you do twenty thousand a
year that's five years if you do thirty
thousand dollars a year thirty three
thousand dollars a year that's three
years and that's the range i want you in
somewhere between there okay and so that
means you're going to pick up some extra
income every chance you get you're going
to throw it at this but it's only going
to be for two or three years and we're
going to knock this in the head you get
in some money from a bonus you get in
money from an inheritance you gettin
money from anything you throw it at this
and you don't do any retirement savings
or anything else while you're working on
this you completely focus on the debt
you have a big student loan problem and
if you don't put all your focus on it's
going to live with you like a fourth kid
yeah and Sallie Mae is an ugly old woman
she a fourth kid you want her out of
your life I know about that all right so
we're going to just be in attack mode
and pound that thing in the face and
then we're gonna get mad we're done with
it and then when you get rid of that
thing you're going to feel like man you
don't feel like the kids left home or
something you don't be just like there's
extra money everywhere and then you
build your emergency fund and then you
start investing in doing kids college
and you'll get there so by the time the
triplets are you know seven eight years
old you're going to be in really good
shape financially and you're going to be
able to aggressively save for their
college and do some other stuff plus
during that time your income will have
come up on a natural curve you know
you're going to see some increases there
right most people do anyway so you know
as your career path trucks along so that
that's the process you use and let me
send you a copy the book the total money
makeover it outlines exactly what to do
and when to do it and how to do it hang
on the line I'll have Kelly pick up and
we'll get you a copy of that it'll be
our gift to you for the triplets
and you guys turn this around and call
me back if you get questions if you're
trying to figure out what to do next
that's what we're here for we will what
we will walk with you this stuff works
dude but you got to hang with a DeCarlo
you got a-you got about four year tough
run here and then you'll be able to get
your head above water and start really
swimming well this is that over MC shall
hey you guys Rachel crews here hope
you're enjoying the dave ramsey show and
did you know that i have my very own
youtube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the dayroom to chamomille
tell them I said that I'm kidding I'm
kidding so subscribe and there's lots of
videos about life and money so while
you're at it if you want to check out a
video then you can check out how to do a
monthly budget it's one of the best
videos out there
you